I've got plenty to be thankful
[Music]
for I needs are small I buy them all at
the 5 and 10 cent store oh I've got PL
to be
[Music]
thankful I used to love this town
until what happened that
night tomorrow's Thanksgiving and I'm
tired of pretending like everything is
normal and it's not I want things to go
back to normal
too show some enthusiasm Thanksgiving is
an institution
here
[Applause]
no no no
no someone's out for revenge and they're
turning it into a sick holiday
game this is
weird we're all tagged and our names are
at the table but why
[Music]
us
the longer this goes the more Twisted it
gets every weapon he's using is straight
off a Thanksgiving table I don't want to
spend my life looking over my shoulders
we need to stop
[Applause]
him
[Music]
it is going to be a very Happy
Thanksgiving let's
see